what is going on everybody welcome to
part four of our web scraping with
beautiful soup 4 tutorial series in this
tutorial we're going to be talking about
is how to scrape dynamically updated
information from a web page so to begin
I have added some information to the
Parkes mEEMIC parse face page underneath
this picture you can see this JavaScript
dynamic data test and it just says look
at you shine in it says that because
we're viewing it with a client in a
browser and the browser is actually
doing something that makes that show up
let's look further
so viewing the source code swimmin in'
scrolling down here is what we're
looking for so this is what we I was
just showing you
whoops okay so what's happening is this
paragraph text is of class JavaScript
test it's got an ID of yes or no or yes
no js' and the starting text is why you
bad though but we didn't see that that's
just the starting text underneath it
we've got a script so JavaScript and
what it's doing is it's finding the
element by an ID that ID is yes no js'
just here and when it finds that it's
going to say the dot enter HTML so we're
going to say okay now the HTML says look
at you shine it that's what we want it
to say so when Google Chrome or whatever
browser are you using browses this page
it says look at you shine it it
requested data from the server and the
initial information that the server said
was no no between the paragraph tags
this is what you want to say but then it
also said here's a script though by the
way and then chrome ran that script
so actually you run that script the
server didn't run that script you ran
that script so closing this out if we
wanted to parse those tags we would use
the following code you don't need to
write this out I mean you can if you
want we're going to use it in a moment
well towards the end but hopefully if
you've been following along you
already have everything up to this just
without these two lines anyway this is
basically the code that we would use
we're going to parse paragraph tags with
the class J's test simple enough so
let's save and run that real quick and
we get why you bad though that's not
even what we thought we were supposed to
get so a lot of times maybe you're going
to parse a webpage that maybe you're
going to parse a table you're expecting
that table to have some data and lo and
behold it has nothing like without so
the problem is you aren't a client
you're not a browser so what we have to
do is mimic being a client or a browser
and actually run that JavaScript which
is actually a little bit more involved
than you might think or maybe you are
thinking that and realizing oh no so so
there's a whole lot of options at our
disposal for how we're going to do this
I think the easiest way to do this is to
use PI QT specifically we'll be using QT
4 I'm sure you can do it QT 5 but I'm
just going to use QT 4 so I do have a
tutorial on PI QT for you don't need to
follow this entire tutorial but you
should go to the first step the first
page and you'll need to get QT 4 if
you're on Windows go to this URL here
and download the wheel for pi QT 4 there
might be an installer now or something
really simple you can check that out if
you're on Windows you can go to
riverbank computing and I think you can
install it from there
it's been so long I don't remember what
method I used on Windows but I have it
it's possible if you're having problems
leave a comment below and I'll do my
best to help you out so once you have QT
4 you're ready to rumble so we're going
to go ahead and come up above these
imports and we're going to start
importing a few new things first we're
going to import sis we're doing that
because QT applications want to be able
to take system arguments and it's going
to be angry if you can't so we're going
to do it then from PI QT 4 and I'm going
to go ahead and just copy this so I
don't type of it but it's capital P
lowercase Y capital Q lowercase T 4 dot
Qt GUI we're going to import Q
application then again and in fact
actually I might as well do
all that from pi q 4 dot QT core we're
going to import q your Alec by the way I
didn't really explain it
q application is probably easy enough
but it's the thing for making
applications q URL this is how we're
actually going to read the URL basically
and then finally QT WebKit actually its
capital K WebKit import q web page
lovely so this is going to let us
actually load the page and act like a
browser act like a client and run that
JavaScript so saving this a ton of
programming is that would be involved
there and in theory you could actually
make the page show up even you can make
your own web browsers in QT 4 as you
might be able to surmise at this point
anyway um cool so we have all the
imports we need and now what we what we
need to do is we're going to write a
client class and if you're not too up to
speed on object-oriented programming
hopefully this one will be super simple
enough I don't yet but very soon I
should have an object-oriented
programming series so if you did if you
are watching this sometime after the
original upload date you should check
out that if you need help anyway class
client client is going to inherit from
the Q web page and we're just going to
make some slight modifications just tiny
ones uh define and we're going to do our
init method it's going to take self and
it's going to take a URL of some kind
what we're going to say is self dot app
is equal to this Q application it
accepts sista argh oh my gosh argh P got
it
then we're going to initialize the Q web
page queue page dots in it
self then self dot load finished dot
connect self dot on page load so we're
initializing the key webpage or
initializing the applet we're starting
up there we're defining the application
in theory we're starting it up it does
this will have its own in it as well but
anyways we are starting up the queue web
page then what we're saying is we're
connecting this method here when the
load is finished what do we want to do
so initially what we could do without
defining this client we could actually
just work directly with the queue web
page with a queue web page object access
the URL and then use this dot mainframe
dot to HTML stuff that I'm going to show
you really quickly you could do that but
the problem is the HTML you would get
would be nothing it would be blank it
would have nothing there because the
page hadn't actually loaded because PI
QT 4 is an asynchronous library so it
runs asynchronously and it's not going
to hang up so it's going to keep doing
code for you so when you go to say ok
this is what the HTML is equal as soon
as it just it initiates that code it's
then going to give you the HTML we don't
want to do that but instead we want to
do is when the load is finished we want
to run on page load whatever on page
load might be we need to define on page
load so define on page load obligatory
self self dot app dot quit that's all
basically we just want this to run until
the page loads and then when the page
loads were done
easy enough now what we're going to say
is
let's see client let's do just move this
down for now I'm going to pull some of
this information so to start we'll say
the URL is equal to this cool then what
we're going to say is the client
response is equal to client and then
we're going to pass that URL which will
go through the init method then we're
going to say the source now the source
code rather than being the URL Lib
request we're going to let QT handle the
source and all this which is kind of
what we're doing up here we're at least
letting QT load the page and then now
we're going to grab the source code from
Q web page basically so the source is
going to be the client response because
this client response is client object
client object is inherited from the q
web page so we can use the q web page
methods now so client response dot main
frame the main frame dot shoot is it I
think get to capital HTML so that's
going to say okay this is basically Q
webpage object let's get the main frame
you know the frame as in the thing that
we're looking at and then convert it to
HTML you could do I don't know if we'd
actually be able to do it I don't want
to do it but you probably could do a dot
show here we'll do it after if this
works we'll do a dot show just to see if
it works
anyway I'm pretty sure it's not show
source although we're running the app
hits prime it wouldn't work I don't
think we could show here I don't know
anyway I don't think it's going to work
so the source we've handled otherwise
everything else stays the same so we
don't need to do anything else let's
save and run that print jas test X none
type has no attribute text what did we
do wrong I'm blaming you all
see client itself that have to quit oh
we didn't finish so it's okay so stupid
okay so after we say basically we needed
to tell it what to do when the loading
is finished before we actually load
anything so what should have really
given it away was the fact that we have
Darrell here and we never actually do
anything with you oh great
okay so self dot main frame and then we
use load and we load the queue you OH
cue URL and then the cue URL loads the
URL and then the app will exit because
we don't actually care that much okay
let's try it one more time boom we got
what we wanted alright so that is that
is how you can scrape dynamic data just
for kicks I want to see if I can
actually show I don't I don't think it's
going to work but yeah yeah because I
guess that's probably more I don't know
I'm not gonna mess with it anymore
anyways so that's how you can scrape
dynamic data no one came here so they
can see it show so I'm not going to
waste any time trying to make that page
show but just know that PI qt4 really is
it's basically a browser and you can
make a browser really easily with QT for
just a little bit more code and we would
be able to make it a browser so a few
things to note one basically you know
it's running it's running it's running
it's running it's right oh there we
finally got a response that took a while
okay why did that take a while well we
would have to look a little deeper but
there's basically whenever you like with
let's say web scraping especially
there's two pain points one pain point
is probably
loading pie QT for loading up this
WebKit stuff loading up our browser
client thing that's going to take some
time to like set all that stuff up okay
and then we're also going to process
whatever javascript is there we have to
process that javascript that's going to
take time okay so that's one thing
also when you're parsing websites the
other thing is just latency in response
time at the server so a lot of people
have asked me as I was released in this
series what do we do about the fact that
beautifulsoup is slow alright beautiful
zhuzh not really that slow I mean it's a
fairly efficient framework the problem
is a server request and response time is
probably going to be like 500
milliseconds or more okay and so it's
not instant so if you're trying to crawl
500 URLs that 500 milliseconds is
suddenly 250 seconds for all 500 URLs
that's a really long time to wait so the
two things you need to think about is if
say you're you're mimicking a client for
that you're going to need to utilize
multi-processing and just like I don't
have yet a tutorial on object oriented
programming I will have a tutorial on
multi-processing
probably within a couple weeks so again
if you're watching this not immediately
or if you are watching this immediately
stay tuned for that uh so if for at
least for using QT and stuff like that
you should use multi processing so if
that's on your side now if it's a
latency issue and you're just simply
waiting for that response
that means your CPU is actually idle
you've got idle threads
thus you can use the threading module
and that will speed up the whole process
and in reality you're going to probably
need to use both okay you're going to
want to make full use because you're
going to be waiting on other people's
processing sometimes and then many times
it's just going to be a bottleneck of
your own processing so keep those things
in mind if you're having speed issues
otherwise that should work for you guys
so if you have questions comments
concerns whatever feel free to leave
them below otherwise as always thanks
for watching things for all sports
subscriptions and it's
next time